[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
e
on
mon
[Musique]
où
et
non
[Musique]
oui
bonjour je m'appelle minaj ans et voix
simon clegg
abraham gomez nous venons de vous
interpréter une pièce baroque avec
traverso et théorbe
parlons tout d'abord dû traverso il
s'agit d'une flûte traversière baroque à
une clé elle a été fabriquée en france à
partir de la fin du xviie siècle
jusqu'au xviiie siècle les ordres
la famille de l'iut a été utilisé à la
même époque
d'abord pour l'accompagnement du champ
certains musiciens utilisent les
instruments d'époque originaux mais la
plupart des musiciens utilisent des
copies d'instruments fabriqués par des
artisans d'aujourd'hui il faut aussi
savoir qu'il n'est pas possible de juger
les instruments à vent originaux du
musée pour des questions de conservation
j'ai donc fait des recherches en 2019
sur la reconstitution d'une flûte
traversière baroque originale à l'aide
des techniques d'impression 3d
le but est de concevoir une copie dans
ce roman rigoureusement identique à
l'original non seulement pour la
recherche historique mais aussi pour que
plus de personnes puissent profiter des
caractéristiques d'un instrument
original
voici le premier prototype d'un traverso
modèle haute et à la 3d
c'est une méthode de production en 3d et
plus rapide
de plus en choisissant en matériau
imperméable la flûte et plus résistantes
à l'humidité et à la déformation ce
projet scientifique a été réalisé entre
autres avec le musée de la musique de
paris cette recherche est toujours en
cours d'avancement
j'espère que cette démarche y
contribuera à démocratiser les
instruments de musique ancienne au près
dans très large public
nous allons maintenant vous interpréter
une pièce de jean baptiste et deux
pouces et intitulée pourquoi de ou
rossignol avec cette flux 3d
[Musique]
e
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]